يقول الكثيرون في أمتنا أنه
إذا حصل دكتور فوسي على اللقاح ،
فسأحصل على اللقاح ، لذا
أخبرنا قليلاً عن سبب
أهميته بالنسبة لي ، فهو مهم لسببين
أحدهما هو أنني طبيب معالج.
هنا
في فريق العمل في المعاهد
الوطنية للمركز الإكلينيكي
الصحي ، ولذا فأنا أرى المرضى ، ولكن
الأهم والأهم من ذلك
هو
أنني أشعر
بالثقة الشديدة في سلامة
وفعالية هذا اللقاح.  أرغب في
تشجيع
كل من لديه الفرصة
للتطعيم حتى نتمكن من الحصول على
غطاء حماية في هذا البلد من
شأنه أن ينهي هذا الوباء ،
شكرًا لك دكتور فكرت لقدومك
اليوم
أي أسئلة تتعلق باللحظة الأخيرة لا ،
حسنًا ، سأفعل ذلك فقط  بعد
قليل ،
أحصل على حقنة عضلية جيدة
هنا ،
شكرًا للمساعدة في
الملعب وقبل أن تتركه
[تصفيق
] يا لها من لحظة للأمة
إليزابيث كوهين
دكتور فوسي ، أنت تعرفه جيدًا وهو يحصل على هذا
لقاح يوضح مدى أهمية
أن يُظهر للأمريكيين أنه آمن ،
كيف كان الحال عند
مشاهدته أنه من الرائع
مشاهدته واعتقدت أنه كان كما تعلم ، ابتسم
عندما رأيت أنه سُئل هل لديك
أي أسئلة؟  أو المخاوف
التي هي بالطبع البروتوكول
ويجب أن تحدث تمامًا ، فأنت تعلم أن
هذا هو الرجل الذي ربما يعرف أكثر
عن هذا اللقاح
أكثر من أي شخص على وجه الأرض تقريبًا ، لذا فإن
ما ينساه الناس أحيانًا هو أن
nih عمل مع
شركة Moderna لإنشاء لقاحات rna-vacs mrna
وقد تم تجربتهم في فيروسات أخرى
ولكن لم يتم طرحها في السوق مطلقًا ، لذلك هذا
هو أول واحد وصل
إلى هذا الحد ، لكن يالها من
لحظة للرجل الذي لعب مثل هذا
الدور في تطوير
هذا اللقاح ليحصل على اللقاح بنفسه